Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein richtig leckeres Rezept, ich freu mich schon voll drauf!
Boah, das war so cringe!
[Hamza] Kiki!
[Kiki] Ja?
[Hamza] Weißt du, du findest das immer richtig lecker!
[Kiki] Ja aber ich mache ja auch nichts, was nicht richtig lecker ist!
[Hamza] Pew!
[Kiki] Pew!
Also wir machen heute eine No Bake Erdbeertorte mit Oreo Boden, mit einer unfassbar leckeren Creme
und mit 'ner richtig tollen Glasur!
Also ich fange jetzt direkt an mit meinen Oreo Keksen, wir brauchen die Creme nicht.
Die bitte rausnehmen, also generell bei diesem Rezept.
Sonst nehme ich die mit in die Creme rein
aber ich möchte nicht, dass es so pappig-süß wird, deswegen brauchen wir das nicht.
Ich bewahre es aber auf für irgendein anderes Rezept, könnt ihr einfach im Kühlschrank aufbewahren.
Und die Oreo Kekse werde ich jetzt klein schreddern und noch geschmolzene Butter dazugeben,
das ist der Boden.
Alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in der...?
[Kiki] Gib mir doch keinen Korb!
[Hamza] Infobox!
[Kiki] Unten in der Infobox. Ich will dich immer einbringen und so und du?
[Hamza] Wie enttäuscht du bist! Die Arme, voll enttäuscht.
[Kiki] Nein! Also ja, ein bisschen aber ist egal.
[Hamza] *lacht*
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch euren Backrahmen.
Entweder einfach auf den Tortenheber geben, das mache ich ja ganz oft bei meinen Rezepten,
oder direkt auf eine Servierplatte, so mach ich's heute.
Und die Maße schreibe ich euch natürlich unten in die Infobox.
Und da geben wir jetzt den Boden rein, also die Oreo Kekse
und drücken den richtig schön flach an.
Ich hab jetzt den Boden komplett mit Erdbeeren belegt.
Einfach vorne neben dem Strunk gerade abschneiden und dann stehen sie auch richtig schön gerade.
Wichtig ist, dass die Erdbeeren auch nicht mehr nass sind, also gut mit 'nem Küchenpapier abtropfen.
Abtrocknen, nicht abtropfen!
Auf jeden Fall werde ich jetzt die Creme zubereiten, die ist sehr, sehr einfach.
Dafür - ich schiebe das mal kurz zur Seite -
Dafür benötigen wir Schlagsahne.
Die ist ganz kalt, die kommt ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank.
Meine Schüssel ist ebenfalls kalt, da habe ich drauf geachtet.
Und jetzt werde ich die Sahne erstmal steif schlagen und gebe dann auch zwischendurch auch Sahnefest mit dazu.
Ja, ist denn sie Sahne auch fest?
Das wollen wir doch mal überprüfen!
Nein, nein, nein, nein! Ich trau mich nicht, ich trau mich nicht!
[Kiki] Die ist bestimmt fest, die ist bestimmt fest!
[Hamza] Probier nochmal! Komm, du Feigling!
[Kiki] Ohoho uhuuu! Nervenkitzel!
Sie ist fest! Macht den Test nicht Zuhause! Vertraut einfach eurer Sahne, dass sie fest ist.
Jetzt geht's weiter in einer anderen großen Schüssel.
Da verrühre ich jetzt Mascarpone, Schmand, Vanilleextrakt und Zucker miteinander
und gebe dann auch nochmal Sahnefest mit dazu.
Mich fragen immer viele aus Österreich, was man statt Schmand nehmen kann.
Ich glaube Schmand gibt's nicht in Österreich.
Vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal reinschreiben, was es da für Alternativen gibt.
Also ihr könntet z.B. auch Crème fraîche benutzen statt Schmand, das würde auch funktionieren.
Aber ich find's auch immer so toll, dass ihr euch in den Kommentaren gegenseitig helft muss ich sagen.
Ganz, ganz wichtig, deswegen betone ich das nochmal:
Ihr dürft diese Masse hier nur 5-8 Sekunden verrühren.
Gerne auch mit 'nem Schneebesen oder mit 'nem Löffel.
Ich hab's jetzt nur mit dem Handrührer gemacht, weil ich den grad da hatte.
Also wirklich nur ein paar Sekunden, maximal 10sek, ansonsten wird's zu flüssig.
Und ich hebe jetzt noch mit 'nem Teigschaber die Sahne unter.
Und dann gebe ich die Creme einmal auf die Erdbeeren in die Backform.
Ich habe jetzt das Ganze nochmal kurz für 20min in den Kühlschrank getan.
Gleich brauchen wir auf jeden Fall noch mehr Kühlzeit aber ich wollte,
dass die Oberfläche schon mal ein wenig fester wird.
Die ganze Creme wird noch richtig schön schnittfest nach der Kühlzeit
aber wir brauchen jetzt einen leckeren Guss.
Ich wollte von Anfang an meine Schokocreme als Guss oben drüber geben,
einfach damit man nicht nur Kuvertüre hat und nicht nur was Süßes
sondern auch was richtig mit Geschmack.
Hier sind ja auch 33% Haselnüsse drin,
das heißt ihr habt nochmal so einen richtig schön nussigen, schokoladigen Abschluss.
Dann hat Hamza sich aber gemeldet und gesagt:
"Warum machst du nicht Haselnuss und Schoko, also gleichzeitig als Guss?"
[Kiki] Ich werd das jetzt machen Hamza, auf deine Verantwortung aber ich stelle mir das..
[Hamza] Mezzo Mix!
Mezzo Mix! Ich stelle mir das auch richtig gut vor.
Also ich werde jetzt meinen Haselnusscreme und meine Schokocreme bei geringer Wattzahl, d.h. 360 W
für ca. 20-30 Sekunden in die Mikrowelle geben
und dann als Guss einfach oben drüber gießen
und das wird dann später auch nochmal richtig schön schnittfest.
Okay, das war eine richtig gute Idee. Also mir gefällt's voll gut!
[Hamza] Pew!
[Kiki] Pew!
Also. Boah, das war voll cringe!
Wir machen jetzt noch Buenos oben drauf, ich finde das passt einfach.
Und vor allem bekomme ich halt immer Feedback von euch - gerade über Instagram - dass meine Haselnusscreme
wie die innere Füllung von Bueno schmeckt.
Bei der Schokocreme sagt ihr immer: wie das Innere von Ferrero Rocher.
Ich werd's auf jeden Fall so mit Bueno dekorieren und ich nehme auch noch Bueno White dazu.
Und ansonsten einfach nur noch 2h in den Kühlschrank geben,
gerne auch über Nacht, dann wird's noch fester.
Und ihr könnt das Ganze dann am nächsten Tag oder am Abend einfach mit 'nem Backformlöser lösen und servieren.
Ich kann leider keinen Taste Taste machen, Hamza auch nicht weil wir sind immer noch mitten im Ramadan,
wir fasten und können nicht probieren aber ich glaube das holen wir auf Instagram nach, oder Hamza?
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall.
Genau, und dann kann man das ja auch im Anschluss nochmal anhängen.
Da kam nämlich letztens auch der Hinweis aus der Community: "Hängt doch einfach eure Taste Tests dann von Instagram an."
[Hamza] Stimmt, das hab ich voll vergessen!
[Kiki] Ja, find ich cool!
[Hamza] Das hab ich mal 'ne zeitlang gemacht.
[Kiki] Ja, hast du 'ne zeitlang gemacht und dann irgendwie nicht mehr.
Also ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen dieser unfassbar leckeren No Bake Torte!
Hinterlasst meinem Kanal natürlich ein kostenloses Abo wenn ihr das jetzt nicht schon längst getan habt.
Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss, eure Kiki!